julie julie je voudrais te parler oui
écoute je suis très occupée c'est
important oui c'est très important
d'ailleurs tout ce qui me concerne est
important les à geron rien tu es comme
tout le monde on tue bien désagréable
aujourd'hui les noms casimir j'ai
beaucoup travaillent alors qu'est-ce qui
était si important que ça joue tu
expliques 1 l'autre jour lui honnart m'a
fait un pied de nez alors moi j'ai
décidé de lui tirer la langue seulement
je me demande s'il vaut mieux que je lui
tire la langue dès qu'il sort de sa
malle ou en face unis mais tu ne
m'écoutes pas facile monsieur mais ces
histoires ne m'intéresse pas mais j'ai
du travail
je savais bien que nous intéresser à
rien
salut françois bon jour qui sait excuse
moi mais j'ai très peu de temps j'ai
beaucoup de clients aujourd'hui et j'ai
énormément de ballons à gonfler normes
il faut que je fasse mes cours ce que
j'ai à te dire est très important on est
dans ces conditions casimir je suis bien
obligé de t'écouter alain bézirard
écoute l'autre en jour léonard marque
fait un pied de nez alors moi j'ai
décidé de tirer la langue à seulement je
me demande s'il vaut mieux que je lui
tire la langue dès qu'il sort de sa
malle ou au contraire si je dois
attendre un certain temps oui je
comprends
que vous dites nous que de noirs mais
mais mais mais enfin pas par du tout
pourquoi nous faut 15 unités des
histoires etc léonarde intéresse
personne alors tu es chantier du chum
bien tu t'en vas là-bas t'amuser à
l'autre bout du jardin qui tu me laisse
travailler à temps je te raconter en
détail non aux musulmans juliette toi
vous ne vous intéressez à rien vous êtes
des égoïstes casimir pour ce que tu veux
ça m'est égal mais le souhait de
travailler aller
non mais vous les avez vu un
je me demande ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour qu'il s'intéresse à autre chose
qu'à leurs skis problème est là à foz
sous ou ce mal que ce passeur monsieur
vous êtes blessé moi
c'est vous savez mes chers amis
c'était arrivé vous avez les noces de
casser en mai je vous envie peut-être et
toutes mes histoires vous avez de
travail s'en doutait pas du tout nous
dérangeait pas du tout me suis pas du
tout content et nous tous un détail bon
alors ce commerçant sur votre chaise mon
cher ami mais je rêve sans trier en
vous avez vu un idylle il suffit qu'il
s'agisse de monsieur du snob et soudain
ils s'intéressent à lui alors là
vraiment s'il suffit de se casser en
hausse eh bien ils vont être servis moi
je ne me casser la figure
de bon je vais demander aux enfants ils
vont m'aider les enfants venaient là
écoutez j'ai besoin de vous
j'ai quelques questions à vous poser
asseyez vous installer mais voilà je
voudrais que vous me disiez quelles sont
les parties du corps où il ya des hauts
et les parties où il n'y en a pas
par exemple
mettons dans la langue qu'est ce que
j'aime en hausse dans la langue
bond dans le temps la jambe et
où elles sont rouges y at il des parties
osseuse encore eu ce qu'il ya des eaux
dans un corps
bras
[Musique]
la main mais il ya des eaux
mon club de coeur le coeur ou est-ce
qu'il est le coeur bon non lula le pied
vous connaissez quelques noms dos
desquels
alors tous que l'on connaît enfin le
tibia tu as dit le petit bien oui
d'accord bon le péroné ah oui peut-être
et oui c'est ça c'est ça c'est un os
dans le bassin oui alors le foie est ce
que j'ai un anneau dans le foie non non
bon on va vous en connaissez d'autres
le crâne rasé le crâne y en a plusieurs
oui je crois d'accord le crâne bien
l'écho par les cours depuis les côtes la
cheville s'est formée de plusieurs zoos
si l'on écouté les enfants je crois que
c'est déjà pas mal j'ai compris tibia
péroné lors il n'y a pas d'eau dans la
langue pas d'eau dans le foie
les poumons
n'ont pas l'eau dans les poumons par
gawker d'accord je crois que ça ira
comme ça je vous remercie un merci
beaucoup vous pouvez aller jouer bien et
bien cette fois ci je trouve ya un moyen
pour les obliger à écouter mon histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je fais des tableaux des pelotes de
laine et quand je suis rentré tous mes
chats s'était amusé les pelotes de laine
je ne les ai pas vus jours quand je me
prends les pibales allait
autrement je tombe dans les escaliers
j'ai mon vieux tu es qu'est-il arrivé
c'est vrai je vois quasiment excuse me
repose toi bien qu'un casimir puisque tu
ne peux pas parler tu va écouter
tranquillement laventure qui est arrivé
à monsieur de snob ah oui très volonté
d'être
[Musique]